Speaker 1: Well, my friends, Joe Biden is doing
it. Joe Biden will be canceling up to $20,000 in
student loan debt for those making under $125,000.
It'll be $10,000 for most folks. But there's a
Pell Grant element to it which could raise that
to $20,000. We're going to look at the details.
And I have to tell you, producer Pat was
completely correct in his prediction. Producer
Pat has been predicting on the award winning bonus
show that at a time advantageous to Democrats
for the midterm elections, Joe Biden would
do some larger student loan forgiveness than
he has done so far. Now, remember that Joe
Biden has already done even before this,
more student loan forgiveness than any other
president. And we've covered that before. And Pat
said it's going to be close ish to the November
midterms. Joe Biden's going to do something.
And I just didn't think he was. And here we are.
Producer Pat, completely correct. New York Times
reporting Biden to cancel $10,000 in student
debt. Low income students are eligible for more.
The plan would be $10,000 in cancelation
for those earning under $125,000 a year
and $20,000 for those who received Pell Grants for
low income families. Now, the debt forgiveness is
less than what some Democrats have been pushing
for, and we will talk about that. Biden also
announced that a pandemic era pause on student
loan payments, which has been in effect since
March of 2020, will expire at the end of the
year. There is not yet an application process.
This has been a big question. Okay. So how do
how do we get the forgiveness if we qualify?
What's the process? That process has not yet been
made specific. A couple of other important notes
here. Students who receive Pell Grants will be
able to get up to 20,000 in forgiveness. About
60% of borrowers have Pell Grants and the majority
come from families earning under $30,000 a year.
The Education Department estimates 27 million
borrowers will qualify for up to 20,000 in relief.
Then you've got millions more who will be able to
get the 10,000. And there are a number of other
repayment modifications that are being made as
well. So let's go through some of the different
reactions to this and then we're going to
delve further into it. So one reaction is
this is not enough. 10,000 is not enough. 20,000
is not enough. Fine, fine. But this is already
overwhelmingly more than any other president
has done by far. So as I've said before,
I tend to evaluate presidents based
on what they do, generally speaking,
and also for things they promised to do but don't
do. I think both are fair game just saying, well,
this president's bad because he didn't do these
ten things that he never promised to do. That
seems to be a way to end up with relatively
meaningless evaluations of presidents. So
when you look at what Joe Biden has done, he has
by far forgiven more student debt than any other
president. Counterpoint Joe Biden is only doing
this to help Democrats in November. Well, I mean,
those and everything politicians do to some degree
is to help themselves. Is it also good for people?
And the answer is this is very good for people.
And there are also some new rules for income based
repayment plans, which are arguably as big of a
deal as the forgiveness repayment will be capped
at 5% of discretionary income rather than ten.
That's a big source of relief. Your payments are
zero if you are below 225% of the federal poverty
line due to an increase in the non-discretionary
fraction of income, unpaid interest is waived
as long as you're making monthly payments,
even if the payments are zero. Based on those
earlier guidelines that I mentioned, and that's
really a game changer. Many people are much more
able to pay off a debt if they're not accumulating
and accruing more and more and more interest
through the payment process. And that's a really
big deal. And then forgiveness after ten years
on loans under $12,000 rather than only $20,000,
which is another interesting provision. So
there is a significant amount of relief here
in addition to the forgiveness component for lower
and middle income borrowers. And that's a really,
really big deal. Now, one question is, what
does this do in terms of Democrat chances
going into the November midterms as we have
talked? About before. Right now in the House
of Representatives, I'm sorry, in the Senate,
the odds for Democrats have crept up from a 52%
shot at holding the Senate to 55. High fifties,
60, and now 64%. Right now, the FiveThirtyEight
estimate, the forecast is that Democrats have a
64% chance of retaining control of the Senate.
We will see whether that number increases on
the basis of this announcement from Joe Biden.
In terms of the House of Representatives,
well, Republicans are still favored to hold,
but by a smaller margin than at any previous
point during this cycle. Right now, Republicans
are down to a 78% chance of taking the House
of Representatives, Democrats at 22%. Still,
the most likely outcome is Democrats. Keep the
Senate but lose the House. But the House numbers
are looking. It's hard to call them good for
Democrats, but they are looking the least bad that
they have looked since we've started following
this election cycle. So this is another major,
major accomplishment by Joe Biden. Later on in
the show, I am going to now compare and contrast.
The one A.D. that has taken place for the
Biden administration, which is which is
truly remarkable. I mean, if you look at the Biden
administration two months ago and now, it is truly
stunning the change that we have seen. We're going
to talk about that and we're going to contrast
that with what's going on on the Republican side,
including a growing civil war wherein former
President Donald Trump is calling for the removal
of Mitch McConnell as the Senate minority leader.
It could not be a greater contrast than what we
are seeing. That'll come up a little bit later.